hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remembered so you don't have to with the
passing of Harold Ramos recently a lot
of people have been wondering if I was
gonna do anything related to arguably
his most popular film ghostbusters it
seemed silly not to seeing how I've seen
this movie more times than I've seen the
Sun but what do you say about a film
that's so popular has already been
talked about to death I mean what am I
supposed to do talk about all the tiny
really unimportant stuff that you never
noticed in the past yes we've all seen
this film a ton of times but the best
movies are the ones you often have to
watch over and over again in order to
catch everything and even though I'm
sure there's more subtle touches
throughout this film these are the ones
that you most likely have missed not
behind the scenes and not in
pre-production but right in front of you
the whole time and I'm here to count
down the top 11 of them today why top 11
because I like to go one step beyond so
sit back enjoy the top 11 moments you
never noticed in ghostbusters I'm 11
this hand is totally copping a feel I
know a lot of people are probably
distracted by the fact that this is such
a shit your pants scary scene but look
at that it's totally manhandling her you
see the one scene where her boob totally
pops out her sweater
you see I don't care if you turn her
into a possessed demon of the night a
bad touch simply won't be tolerated no
one has the right to touch you if you
don't want them to you tell on side
number 10 the Stay Puft Marshmallow Man
actually appears three times in the
movie we all know the final Big Finish
but he also appears in Dana Barrett's
groceries and on the side of a billboard
when the ghosts are released guess he
just want to make his role bigger cuz
well he wasn't big enough
mago Hoss bucket number 9 econ looks
down at his mark during their commercial
this matches perfectly as lays clearly
too into his role are you troubled by
strange noises in the middle of the
night Peter can barely give a crap you
any of your family ever seen a spook
Specter or ghost and Egon can't even
manage to keep eye contact with the
camera you experience feelings of cred
in your basement or attic top it all off
with these three awkward smiles and you
got a nebula never forget we're ready
number eight nobody is checked by the
ENT except for Lewis for some reason
it's understandable that after
destroying a giant marshmallow man and
crossing the streams that could have
possibly resulted in total atomic ripple
that some medical attention or doctor
check up would be required and yet Lewis
is the only one who seems to get it why
David Barrett was a dog too no he's
right how come he can't go with them in
the car there's no reason not to why
does he get the special treatment by not
getting the special treatment well let's
just end with Dana and Peter giving an
awkward kiss - a loving kiss - Peter
showing off making it an awkward kiss
again what a hassle number seven does
this line sound familiar
go get alright yeah the joke is that
Peter is speaking for them as a team and
then sends in ready to do the hard work
but does it possibly remind you of an
earlier scene get her yep the joke has
suddenly made funnier when you realize
that this is all part of Peters sweet
revenge for getting their asses scared
off earlier even down to using the exact
same term gather thanks very much right
number six how do poor people afford
video games the Ghostbusters constantly
talk about how they're tight for money
in the first half of the movie well if
that's the case where the hell did they
get three arcade games frog what's Atari
really so important that you couldn't
live without it this magnificent feast
here represents a blast of the petty
cash well at least we have the Beach
Trouble in Little China pinball game or
whatever that is number five when
figuring out the price for their first
job you got signals Peter for how much
it costs of course when they start off
they've claimed they've done this a
million times we handle this kind of
thing all the time but when it comes to
the numbers they're still not sure what
the protocol is but they want to look
more professional than they are so they
work off each other to figure out the
exact amount
now for the entrapment we're going to
have to ask you for four big ones $4,000
for that but we are having a special
this week on proton charging and storage
of the beast and that's only going to
come to $1,000 7ek number four you
remember the Ghostbusters burning up the
cleaning woman's card but did you ever
notice that you try to put out the fire
with Windex does that work
maybe My Big Fat Greek Wedding was right
number three Ron Jeremy Carl Winslow and
Ivan Reitman all make appearances yep
right after the containment unit is shut
down one of the onlookers is strangely
enough the famous porn star ron jeremy
he doesn't seem to play a porn star in
this unless he was on his way to a shoot
however Family Matters star Reginald
veljohnson does play a cop just like he
did as Carl Winslow okay ghost but mayor
wants to see you guys his appearance is
brief but like most people we'd like to
think that his role here he's rolling
family matters and his role in die hard
were all the same guy just undercover
help maybe the kid he shot in die hard
was Steve Urkel
and yes even the film's director was in
this movie cordially supplied the voice
for both Slimer and zoo well tackle
Peter the lovely singing voice you must
have number two the climax starts out
during the day goes in tonight but then
suddenly comes out day again okay we can
give the movie a little bit of leeway in
terms of how long the final battle took
but eight hours even if you argue that
goes are made this guy dark it still
clears up to reveal stars after she's
destroyed the climax is at maximum
twenty minutes long but the movie is
indicating that it took over maybe seven
hours by god did it really take them
that long to go up those stairs next
time try taking ecto - yeah
do more damage that way and the number
one moment you never noticed in
ghostbusters is Walter Peck is 100%
right I know I'm not the first person to
say this the Peck is totally justified
in what he is doing he may be one of the
most enjoyable hateable characters in
movie history but what is he trying to
do he wants to examine their business
because he thinks it's unstable Peter
turns him down because it is unstable
beyond belief when they turn on the
proton packs they back away from they
openly acknowledge they have never
tested their equipment you know it's
just occurred to me we really haven't
had a completely successful test of this
equipment and pretty much every other
scene indicates that none of their
incredibly dangerous devices are up to
date there's something very important I
forgot to tell you how's the grid oldman
not good
turning it off would be like dropping a
bomb in the city each of us is wearing
an unlicensed nuclear accelerator on his
back every molecule in your body
exploding at the speed of light this is
a nuclear bomb waiting to go off and
granted Peck is still dickless for
turning off the containment unit not
knowing what it'll do
but how can something that dangerous
that ends up destroying the city only
have three people that know how to
handle it they didn't even bring their
new cool member up to date this shut off
the protection grid oh great that's bad
hell we're trusting these guys with the
fate of our city yeah pecks a jerk yeah
we love to hate him but let's face it as
much of a douchebag as he is these
fuckers are much more dangerous you guys
are full of crap and that's why you went
out of business
I'm grateful little yuppie larva now of
course there's a lot more than just 11
little things that you never know is
dead a movie this good but I only have
11 slot so if there's anything you
notice that maybe the majority of people
haven't list in the comments below and
keep talking about one of the most
talked about movies of all time I'm the
Nostalgia Critic I remember it so you
don't have to
you
hey guys Doug Walker here two things for
you real quick number one then did you
like this video the reason we asked even
though people leave comments and say
what they think all the time oh we were
thinking about turning this into a
regular series because there's a lot of
movies that we sadly have watched a
million times and you notice all things
in the background that are kind of fun
to bring up uh so we're wondering if
maybe we can do this with other
nostalgic movies and people be
interested in it maybe that would sort
of be the thing that pops up every other
week in between the reviews there's
gonna be other toriel's every once in a
while but we were thinking about doing
this because it's just a fun thing and
we noticed this stuff and we like to
hear other people share in the comments
like hey and you ever know is this about
this movie and so on and so forth and we
want thank you very much what you see
not necessarily what went into the
making of it or the background story you
can go online you can see a bunch of soe
we like very much that it was always in
plain sight and you never noticed it so
uh yeah let us know if you like that
this is something you'd like to see more
of uh number two I have one more
Ghostbusters story and I didn't put this
on the list because like I said it
didn't really connect with what you saw
but it's just a funny story and has
nothing to do with anything but it's
it's just a cute story so okay you
remember the scene where they're just
about to go into business there they
just got thrown out of the college and I
gotta go in the guy started up they're
drinking they're kind of getting bust we
asked our dad we said what is that that
they're drinking and he didn't really
want to say what alcohol was and that
they were probably little tipsy one they
did this and that's how he kind of
convinced Frey to go into it so he made
up the idea that that's the magic drink
that turns them into ghostbusters and
the only reason I bring this up is
because if you watch that scene watch it
with the idea that that is the magic
drink that turns him into ghostbusters
because once ray drinks it he starts
talking really smart and really
scientific and throwing out all these
terms this ecto containment system that
Spangler and I have in mind is going to
require a load of bread to capitalize
and then Peter drinks it and suddenly
they're often they're getting the
firehouse and they're getting the
equipment together and stuff and it's
just for years when I was a little kid
that's what I thought that stuff was I
thought was the magic
they don't gills Buster's so it has
nothing to do with anything but I
thought it's a funny little story and I
just share with you so sorry I can't
wasting your time it's just a cute
loafing so uh that's about it let us
know if you enjoyed this video and again
share a bunch of our stuff that maybe me
or other people didn't notice about
Ghostbusters because it's a great movie
there's a lot of little stuff to notice
take care